well,
a man is in custody after
barricading himself for several hours to give
health to cristian cásseres I tell you that
the metropolitan police responded to a
call around eleven thirty on
Sunday night from a woman
believed to be a hostage and suspects  he
barricaded himself inside an apartment
located on rainbow boulevard and
govern street the accounts of
nate's family and friends in valencia said their
last goodbyes on sunday this
wannabe student died last month during
a benefit fight organized
by a fraternity  some changes are expected
in the
nevada state athlete commission after this incident
to prevent future
unauthorized fights and more deaths the
scappini children's museum will be offering
free cob vaccinations for children and adults
on monday the clinic  it will be from 11 in
the morning until 3 in the afternoon, no
appointment is needed for anyone who
receives  a vaccine and you will get two passes
to the museum this same site is
planning additional clinics for the
month of March and we close with a look
at the weather forecast as we can
see we will have
partly cloudy skies with highs
reaching 55 degrees temperatures will rise a
bit for the  Tuesday
and Wednesday approaching 60
degrees, however the rain could return
for Christmas Eve and also
Christmas I am Cristian Cásseres with his
brief Spanish edition news
good day
[Music]